good afternoon
today i'd like to update uh you all on
where we stand on covet 19.
because of the strategy we executed over
the past year on vaccinations testing
treatments
and more
we're now in a new moment in this
pandemic
does not mean that covet 19 is over
it means that covet 19 no longer
controls our lives that's what it means
cases are ticking up as we thought they
might
but now thanks to the foundation we've
laid america has the tools to protect
people all people
and you know as we've done from day one
my administration is making it easier
than ever for america to access these
tools
today i'm announcing the launch of
covet.gov
cova.gov
excuse me a one-stop shop
where anyone in america can find what
they need to navigate the virus
free vaccines
and boosters
free at home test
high quality masks
and uh for the latest information about
the level of covet 19 spread in your
community you can get that immediately
now you'll also be able to find our new
test to treat locations which i
announced in my state of the union
address
these are pharmacies and other places in
your neighborhood where you can get
tested and if you're positive you can
get life-saving treatments all in one
stop
we've already stood up two thousand
tested street sites to test and treat
sites across the country
we're also nearly at we have nearly 200
sites just to serve military families
and veterans communities as well
we've done what we've done throughout
the pandemic we've ensured
these locations are the hardest hit
hardest to reach communities as well
the bottom line
no longer will americans have to scour
the internet to find vaccines treatments
tests or masks
it's all there
and just go visit covet.gov
cova.com
and let me remind you when i took office
about 14 months ago the pandemic was
raging the economy was reeling and the
deficit was soaring
most schools were closed
we didn't have enough vaccines the
unemployment claims were sky high
and then we got to work and we delivered
enough vaccines for every american
months ahead of schedule
effective treatments
at home tests that are free and
accessible
over 99 of our schools are open again
businesses are open again and because of
how we responded we created more jobs
last year than ever before
6.6
million jobs and by the way
we did it while cutting the deficit the
largest one-year deficit reduction in
american history say that again the
largest one-year deficit reduction in
american history
but none of that happened by accident
we're able to do it because we
coordinated across the government
partnering with state and local leaders
governors on both sides of the aisle and
the private sector to leverage every
resource we had to fight against this
virus
we left no stone unturned
and we were able to do it because
congress worked with us and provided us
the necessary funding
but now
just as we've reached the critical
turning point in this fight
congress has to provide the funding
america needs to continue to fight
covert 19.
well we're already seeing the
consequences of congressional inaction
the monoclonal antibodies take
monoclonal item bodies for example
they've helped save lives this isn't
partisan it's medicine
but congress hasn't provided enough
money to keep purchasing these
monoclonal
antibodies
we've had to cancel planned orders and
cut the supply we're sending to the
states
without more funding we'll start to run
out of them by the end of may
the end of may
we've also had to scale back our plan to
purchase more preventive therapies for
americans who are immune
immunocompromised
critical tools to protect the most
vulnerable among us
without more funding we risk running out
of the supply by this fall
the same is true of testing it took much
to ramp up our testing capacity the
omicron we saw how vital and with lumber
crime we saw how vital it was
and we have enough tests on hand to
weather the surge but without funding
we're not going to be able to sustain
the testing capacity beyond the month of
june
and if we fail to invest
we leave ourselves vulnerable if another
wave of the virus hits
look
on vaccines and most important tool in
this fight we're also running a risk
yesterday the food and drug
administration the fda and the center
for disease control and prevention the
cdc authorized the fourth shot
for those 50 years and older
we know boosters are critical to
providing an additional level of
protection
that's why i plan to get my second
booster today uh right here after i'm
done speaking
if you haven't gotten your first booster
please don't wait
do it today
those who are 50 and older as well as
those who are
immunocompromised
can now get it get even more protection
than they have from the initial uh first
doses
we have enough supply to give booster
shots to those newly eligible
individuals but if congress failed to
act we won't have the supply we need
this fall to ensure the shots are
available free
easily accessible for all americans
even worse
if we need a different vaccine for the
future to combat a new variant we're not
going to have enough money to purchase
it
we cannot allow that to happen
congress
we need to secure additional supply now
now
we can't wait until we find ourselves in
the midst of another surge to act it'll
be too late
and we also need this this funding to
continue our efforts to vaccinate the
world
with commitments we made it's critical
to our ability to protect against new
variants there's no wall you can build
high enough to keep out a virus
congress needs to act now please
let me close with this
i've worked so hard to get our lives
we've worked so hard to
we all of us have worked so hard to get
our lives back
we're summoning every ounce of american
resilience
pulled every lever of our government
called upon the goodness decency and
patriotism american people
together we turned an unthinkable pain
into an extraordinary progress and
purpose
americans are back to living their lives
again
we can't surrender that now
congress please act you have to act
immediately the consequences of an
action are severe
they'll only grow with time
but it doesn't have to be that way
we've proven what we can do when we work
together so i urge democrats and
republicans to get this done with
urgency
let's stand united let's continue to
pull together let's get this done
thank you and god bless you all and may
god protect your troops and i'm going to
get my second booster shot
mr president what is the danger of putin
being left in the dark by his military
advisors
that he doesn't trust his military
leadership since it is declassified
now
[Music]
[Music]
we'll have a decision on that soon
what did president zalinski tell you
about
somebody asked about the vaccine
i've always thought that it discourages
people getting the vaccination when i
watch people get a needle in their arm
so uh i apologize for the scratching it
didn't hurt a bit
and i was able to roll my sleeve up and
thank you all
[Music]
we're trying to work that out
what did president zielinski tell you
what did president zielinski tell you
about negotiations